was ist im erdmagnetfeld verantwortlich
der flüssige anteil und der harte er
kann dafür aber wie setzt sich der
erdgas zusammen das war bisher unbekannt
bisher was dort wird gerade zu tun hat
das gibt es jetzt wirklich zum schein
sind wissen und uhr übrigens heute
aussehen wo ich auf dem ausweis aus
wetzlar auf dem vatikan kenne gesessen
habe herzlich willkommen über den
inneren erdkern was die forschung noch
lange nicht alles was er in
zusammenspiel mit dem flüssigen zeit
darum herum den äußeren er kann für das
erdmagnetfeld verantwortlich ist steht
fest ohne diese schützende fällt wäre
leben auf der erde nicht möglich der
innere kern hat einen durchmesser von
rund 5100 kilometer
der druck dort beträgt 3,6 4 millionen
war und es ist ganz schön warm dort
unten von 5700 der erdkern besteht zum
größten teil aus eisen und ein wenig
mittel enthält aber auf 15 prozent
weitere elemente wie sauerstoff schwefel
kool savas und so weiter lohse vom
institut für technologie in tokio ganz
schön was los llanos den vorschlag war
wird er allerdings nicht ganz klar wie
sie elemente anteilsmäßig zusammensetzen
daher haben sie ein experiment gestartet
diese frage zu klären
der nackte tatsachen dazu nahmen sie im
erdkern enthaltenen elemente und
erhitzen liebe mit einem leser auf bis
zu 4.500 affäre um den verhältnissen im
erdinnern näher zu kommen sollten sie
außerdem mit hilfe einer diamant
schimpfte presse einen druck von 450
megawatt untersuchte sie welchen
regierungen sich unter diesen
bedingungen will die zitat in der
vergangenheit hat sich die forschung zu
regierungen im erdkern meisters auch
regierungen aus eisen mit einem weiteren
element konzentriert aber wir haben uns
entschieden in unseren experimenten
regierungen mit zwei zusätzlichen
elementen zu setzen von denen wir
glauben dass sie beide im erdkern
vorkommende chirurgisch für der
vorgehensweise der forscher es kam
allerdings nicht zur bildung einer eisen
regierung wie man es vielleicht erwartet
hätte stattdessen entstand wie lithium
wie gedacht gibt nichts anderes als was
aber bitte nicht mit sand verwechseln
fahrt ins wendland enthalten aber sand
ist im umkehrschluss nicht zwangsläufig
vater wirklich gespannt der kindes
pazzini zum wirklich wurde ab einem
gewissen grad der abfüllung während des
experiments zu kristall und herr
hinterließ sein dass ein
das gibt den forschern aufschluss über
die möglichen anteile von silizium und
sauerstoff innerhalb des erst wenn
dieser prozess mit sie nicht um hierfür
könnte sich glaubt genau wie im
experiment abgespielt haben kann nur bei
einem bestimmten verhältnis der beiden
elemente entsteht jetzt passiert ja
immer mehr irgendwie aber beim thema
außerdem würde dies so die
zusammensetzung des erdinneren wird der
langsamen abkühlung des planeten über
die zeit verändern zitat der forscher
eine abkühlung um 100 verlieren würde
unserem thermodynamischen modell nach zu
einer rund zwei kilometer dicken schicht
aus reinem sie hinzu
der kernmantel grenze für zitat ende
für die forscher hatte dieser mögliche
protest eine weitere folge die tat wenn
die kristallisation in geringerer tiefe
beginnt sammelt sich das eto zweier
sowie wirklich an der oberseite des fern
die wichtel rechts flüssigkeit mit
weniger mit demis jung und sauerstoff
klingt dagegen in den tiefen kann auf
die tabelle und das wiederum müsste das
magnetfeld beeindrucken die forscher
glauben auch das experiment zeigt woher
die energie in der jungen phase der erde
kam
um den erdball amo in gang zu bringen
und so das erdmagnetfeld überhaupt
auszubilden
die rose unsere berechnungen zeigen dass
die kristallisation von silizium chip
eine immense energiequelle für das
magnetfeld gewesen sein könnte die tat
könnte was ich sonst noch so über die
letzten rund 14 milliarden jahre im
universum abgespielt hat könnt ihr euch
über unseren link in der video
beschreibung oder vier unter den key
anhören einfach draufklicken probe abo
abschließen unter turbo die kürzeste
geschichte allen lebens für eine
reportage über 13,7 milliarden jahre
werden untergehen wie fängst du mal
wirklich spaß dabei und wenn er weiter
jeden tag videos geben wollte dank mehr
hier sein aber aufs auge und haut mehr
einen auch die glocke auf jeden fall
dann werde ich nicht mehr fassen
ansonsten gittern bleibt